civil rights hero john lewis will be
laid to rest today in atlanta yesterday
he was carried through the streets of
the city on his way to the state capitol
the funeral will be held later this
morning at ebenezer baptist church
speakers include former presidents bill
clinton and george w bush
former president barack obama will
deliver the eulogy
and in the new york times this morning
lewis final essay
which was set to be published on the
morning of his funeral
it has an urgent message for the civil
rights activists of today he says this
though i may not be here with you i urge
you to answer the highest calling of
your heart
and stand up for what you truly believe
in my life
i've done all i can to demonstrate that
the way of peace
the way of love and non-violence is the
more
excellent way now it is your turn to let
freedom ring
when historians pick up their pens to
write the story of the 21st century
let them say that it was your generation
who laid down the heavy burdens of hate
at last
and that peace finally triumphed over
violence aggression and war
so i say to you walk with the wind
brothers and sisters
and let the spirit of peace and the
power of everlasting love
be your guide boy now let's go to the
ebenezer baptist church in atlanta
cbs this morning saturday co-host
michelle miller is outside michelle
those words just give me goosebumps they
are so powerful and so uniquely
so uniquely john lewis
i couldn't say it better gail good
morning to you and as you all know
ebenezer baptist church here where i'm
standing has had a long-standing history
dr martin luther king jr preached here
he's actually buried
just next to the old sanctuary across
the street
and it's the church congressman lewis
called home
lewis married his wife lillian here they
were both
lifelong members and this is where the
world will say goodbye to him
one by one mourners went to the georgia
state capitol to pay their respects to
civil rights leader
john lewis a man who dedicated his
entire life to fighting for equal rights
now the boy from troy will be laid to
rest in the state he's represented for
more than three decades
earlier wednesday congressman lewis left
the u.s capitol for the last time
as his fellow lawmakers said goodbye
john lewis made it clear to us
that when we see wrong when we see
things that need to change
we should find a way to get in the way
mourners greeted him in atlanta lining
the streets as a hearse carrying his
casket
rolled through downtown it stopped
briefly at a mural of lewis
inscribed with the word hero may his
words
actions and legacy continue to serve as
our country's conscious
georgia governor brian kemp and atlanta
mayor keisha lance bottoms
praised lewis for his lifelong fight for
equality which continued right up to his
recent visit to black
lives matter plaza in washington d.c
bottom said his push to get into good
trouble
has inspired her actions as a leader and
so governor when the good trouble
continues
know that it is with the blessings of
congressman lewis
he was warm and gentle and thoughtful
and while the nation
has lost an incredible historical figure
i've lost my dear friend
former atlanta mayor bill campbell was
friends with lewis for more than 40
years
he says lewis leaves a legacy that will
rival some
of the greatest icons in history when
history is written it will reflect the
great figures of the 20th century
and john lewis will be right beside
those incredible figures
of course mayor campbell will be at the
services along with ambassador andrew
young the wife of
hank aaron these were couples really who
were best friends with the congressman
and his late wife lillian
we should note that after the funeral
the motorcade will take the body of
the congressman past atlanta city hall
the capitol
on to southview cemetery that is where
lily and his wife is buried
and several churches around the country
also plan to do
their part to honor the congressman
today at 11 a.m during the funeral
services
houses of worship plan to ring their
bells for 80 seconds to honor the 80
years
john lewis lived gail
michelle i talked to ambassador young
yesterday he mentioned the conversation
the interview that he had with you and
he said listen
we should all remember that john lewis
started this work this
the civil rights work at the age of 15.
he made it to 80.
he said that is victory that is a
celebration and now it's time for him to
go home
i thought that was very well said too
time for that rest yes
very well said
his family described him as a humble
simple man but to the very end he
devoted his life to making this world a
better place
for all of us thank you michelle